so what is working right now to get
views on YouTube and what are the best
tactics for growing your channel
breaking through a plateau if you've
noticed that your views are down in
today's episode of the think media
podcast I have two special guests we're
going to be actually doing a deep dive
on a gardening Channel talking about
tactics for growth and there'll be
lessons we can all learn and then we're
also going to be doing a deep dive on a
real estate channel that is using video
marketing and using YouTube to basically
grow their business and so if you're a
business owner or wanting to learn some
more advanced strategies we're going to
be hitting that and then I want to
encourage you take advantage of the time
codes and chapters because those will
organize where we have the deeper dive
coaching sessions and then q a so I'll
be answering the questions of the guests
that are live today and you'll be able
to go take advantage of those specific
questions so that you can ultimately
grow your channel faster my name is Sean
Cannell and this is the coffee with
Channel show
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
here at think media for live streaming
to Facebook and YouTube and for
recording our video podcast it has an
incredibly easy to use interface for
built-in branding transitions text lower
thirds and seamlessly bringing on guests
and they just added an awesome new
feature called local recording this
allows you to take the quality to
another level by separating out your
audio and video from your guests giving
you more control over your content for
later use this feature is perfect for
video and podcast creators and so to get
a special deal on stream yard right now
and to see all the features that are
included just go to stream with
think.com that is stream with think.com
welcome back to the coffee with candle
show today I'm sipping on some Ethiopia
yoga Chef Coffee single origin black and
white coffee roasters
okay
well so good and I'm curious what are
you drinking if you're here live uh
we're about to dive in with Robert and
one of the cool things though about our
sponsor stream yard is the ability to
produce a show like this we actually
multi-stream on YouTube and Facebook the
fact we can bring in guests create
content
um and uh have all these different
features where we can play videos and
integrate all that kind of stuff so
check out streamwiththink.com if you
haven't tapped into the power of stream
yard yet a huge asset that we love using
here at think media but today let's get
into our first coaching session with
Robert Kennedy III Robert welcome to the
show
hey Sean listen I'm so glad to be here
buddy huh hold on
whoa you got the skills man how'd you do
how did you do the confetti that was
powerful oh I know well that that's the
you know uh stream deck
nice
yeah that's amazing well um hey tell us
a little bit about you what you do I'm
gonna pull your channel up so people can
see your content tell us about your
history and then we'll get into your
specific questions
fantastic so I am my my core is
communication I work with real estate
agents real estate associations and
brokerages now specifically about how to
be more confident on camera how to
communicate more effectively and how to
present their ideas with with confidence
and so public speaking presentation
skills that's kind of the core of what I
do and I do some of that in the area of
video these days and that's my history
my gosh yeah I don't know that's a lot
how long have you been doing the channel
you know so I've had my channel I would
say
[Music]
so he's showing old stuff so I've had a
channel for a while but I think it's
just in the last six or seven months
that I said okay you know what let me
not just put stuff on there
um let me become a little bit more
targeted and serious with what I'm doing
and even then it's still been
um consistency has been a a struggle
with with lifeing yeah but gotcha well
excited to help uh today and so we'll
jump into your first question you know
your audio does sound good but there is
a little click kind of clicks on and off
clicks on and on it's not like a clip
Audio Level sounds really great but
there's some kind of a clicking noise
and so uh you know where mid talk so no
big deal I think everything's coming
across fine but just FYI if that's ever
happened before and there's some easy
fix for it
um but let me know
um what uh your question is as we dive
in and I can give some feedback on your
channel as well
yeah I think the the big question is the
in going through the the uh ours the
seven R's here I've done the research
and I've done you've tried the community
tab idea did some questions on LinkedIn
through my mailing list and I get
questions from answer the public and all
of those different places but I don't
feel like I'm really hitting questions
that my audience is specifically asking
me that and I don't know that I'm having
some success there so I'm struggling
with where to go all in here some of the
questions that I get are technology
related and some are communication
related and I'm kind of trying to figure
out okay what's that space that I really
lean into that will cause people to come
to the channel as a resource
yeah so
um you know when we teach answer
specific questions
you mentioned a few tools that everybody
listening can take advantage of I think
you know answerthepublic.com is a
website also ask.com people should tap
into vid IQ has
um kind of their keyword research tool
and will show you trending videos
um but I do think there's also the
opportunity to
just turn the consistent questions that
your audience asks you into videos so
let me ask you have you how many people
are like on your email list or or maybe
your core following you have 1 600
subscribers but
how about email list do you have phone
numbers in your business
we're not that big in the phone numbers
we do have some text that's probably in
the low hundreds at this point we've
probably got about two two thousand plus
on the email list that we're using right
now
see like one of my favorite things to do
in your situation would be to like
schedule a free Zoom call
um and in terms of
really
because we say the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins so if
you like you're saying Hey how do I
really get in touch with the questions
and the pain points in my audience you
have a unique Advantage for some they're
starting from scratch and they don't
have 2 000 emails and a couple hundred
on a text list
um and you can do this at any level but
Mike my thought is if you could get 10
it could be less than that but but
chances are the size of your list you
could probably get 5 10 15 20 people
that in a way the smaller the group the
better and just to have some
conversations
um for me this a lot of times happens at
events I just got back from Miami At The
Vault conference and you know I was in a
room for of CEOs who paid ten thousand
dollars a ticket
the mindset that could block people
right was like oh well these are
Advanced people clearly they um
this is what I think they need and
here's what I've learned we're all
basically 100 wrong when we think we
know what people need
and even if we kind of have an idea of
what they need how they would word it
the level of sophistication I was
talking with another pretty significant
influencer in my DMs you know and she
was asking about tech things
and uh I started to ask even are you
running the camera do you have someone
on your team running the camera you got
to understand like the unique pain
points
of your target audience
and then you also want to recommend
recognize patterns because some of our
most viral content and when I say viral
we teach vfm viral for me so viral might
just be 10 000 views like if you had a
10 000 viewed video right that would
you'd be like oh my gosh that's 100x
than some of my other views well when
you strike a chord and you really
position what it is people are looking
for what it is they want
um
then things then growth can really
follow so I think there's out of an
actual kind of case study focus group
what um and what I've been I brought in
out what other channels do you watch on
YouTube I would ask this group what um
how what are the ways you're trying to
grow your business I wouldn't
necessarily just say what videos do you
want me to make I would just be trying
to like really understand them how much
time a week do you have to create
content how much
um what kind of content do you want to
create what you know and I would ask I
would come up with like 30 good
questions you're just kind of learning
and you find out that okay you end up
coming with a title that's like how to
you know grow your real estate business
in under five hours a week and then the
hook of that video and the thumbnail and
everything ends up it ends up kind of
going viral in the real estate community
and event and leading you to more
clients than you could ever handle like
you're one video away from from like
doubling or 10x in your business on the
other side of the power of the YouTube
algorithm but there is the hard work of
figuring out the clarity of what are
people going through and that isn't a
one-time thing that is a lifestyle the
content creator lifestyle is this is why
we consistently ask Community tab
questions
um on your community tab looks like you
have a good one here you know what's the
biggest mistake that people make when
when uh doing video this is interesting
we could do this together on coffee with
candle boring cheap equipment no
structure bad lighting probably boring
or no structure for me is the biggest
mistake that I would think man I'm torn
I'm gonna vote
uh I think that uh I think that boring
not relevant and that's 50
uh bad lighting was another one so you
also could do an open-ended question and
you do you're doing it so hey you know
props to that and I see this isn't
really getting distribution that was
five months ago though so and and if if
you're not getting data and feedback
there that's why I would tap the list
and maybe you know you might even do a
giveaway like I'm going to be giving
away a free coaching session or just
something but like you want to get
people what's also wild is actually from
business owner to business owner if 22
people jump on that Zoom call it it
probably could leave the business
directly too like two of those people
end up wanting to work with you so that
the ROI of doing that is a whole
separate thing um not understanding
fully your business but if like that's I
think there's that opportunity but
there's nothing more valuable than the
Creator who understands if your best
wins and I would argue this
I've been doing this I've been doing
YouTube 16 years video for 20.
Nolan malt Omar Al to Corey Kyle
Anderson
um our YouTube experts we've been doing
growth video live for five years
um Andrea Melissa all of us like you
know this is the thing media team you
know like we've had we've had moderate
success people might say they look at
our podcast Channel our other channel
here's my mentality
we don't even know who we're talking to
yet we don't understand our audience we
need to ask better questions we need to
understand them deeper we need to have
greater empathy
sometimes in think media Nolan would
tell you be like bro why are we making
these videos like what are we even why
don't we actually make videos aligned
with the pain are we answering questions
no one's asking and and this isn't
keyword research this is like a deeper
level than that
and and I'll oftentimes talk to our team
it's like after we've won the game we
get in the locker room and talk about
how we can do better so a lot of times
I'm like it's good like if you're doing
answer the public that's great keyword
research that's great too but I think
the mentality is is the shoshin always
come back to a beginner mentality and
there's so much gold waiting for this is
a this is true for the product you
create the offer you create the videos
you create The Branding the positioning
you resonating with the customer you
resonating with people what people often
say you will always make the sale and
you will always get the customer when
you can explain
the prospect's problem better than they
can like when you understand even what
they're struggling with in their mind
better than them the only way to do that
is by talking to them and I know I've
answered long here but I feel like this
conversation is has some good value I
learned an aha moment from Dave Ramsey
who's been on the radio for 30 years and
YouTube for 10 and 20 million views a
month and he's building up a whole
empire and you know 400 million dollars
a year in his business I don't quote me
on that whatever something like that and
uh and and one of the things his staff
has told me at multiple levels of the
company
as they said
Dave
understands and is closer to our
community than anybody else in the
company 1200 employees Dave has more
empathy and connection with the
community and why does he go live for
two hours a day answering caller
questions five days a week two hours a
day it used to be three hours a day
because he doesn't want to become too
far removed because everything that he
hears as he actually has real
conversations with people's voice that's
why I want you to schedule a zoom call
or
one-on-one phone calls text people and
be like hey I'm doing free 30-minute
coaching sessions text me back and I'll
jump on the phone with you right now
like talk to one person
why because he starts to hear their
stories their pain Point what they're
going through and there's so many
misconceptions and mindsets that we all
create and even if we started well we
start to have this distancing that
happens all this expertise that you've
already built creates distance from the
person who's just starting and their
fears and their uh the emotions they're
going through and all these different
things and so the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins by the
way this is now getting kind of meta one
of the reasons I'm recommitted to coffee
with candle is to hang out with you
I'm so busy trying to like
CEO responsibilities and like meetings
and and talking about content and doing
all this kind of stuff and like and on
the one hand even doing this quote
unquote doesn't make sense and it was
actually Dave who re-inspired me where I
was like this is the most important part
of my week is going to be my
conversation with you and then my
conversation with dirt musicians and
then uh the Q a after this because I
need to like stay into like what are the
pain points so has this been helpful I
mean I think this could really
yeah absolutely absolutely I'm I am
already committing to getting that call
scheduled before the end of this month
or within the next two weeks and then
just starting to push out requests to
hop on that Zoom call so yeah absolutely
man
all right next we'll land the plane here
but uh let's look at your channel and
I've got some feedback with you as a for
your channel is that cool I'm excited
let's go
all right so uh
the the having said all of that I think
there's another opportunity that you
have and there's a couple things that
that jump off
uh the page immediately
one
it's a little busy titles even feel a
little busy and thumbnails feel a little
busy for me
so how real estate agents can create
videos easily using chat GPT and other
AI tools
just long and it's makes sense but then
what also is is tough so to kind of try
to break this into
tips
less text in the thumbnail
do not Echo the title in the thumbnail
so the fact that the title already says
this it says that the the thumbnail
doesn't need it
um
it could say something different that's
your opportunity is the thumbnail can
say something different than what the
title says yep and then think about how
you could maybe simplify some of these
titles down so I like
one of the things I like to think about
video is is similar to a funnel
and so let me start with like email
marketing what is the purpose of an
email subject line
the purpose of an email subject line is
only one thing get someone to stop and
open the email
what is not the purpose of an email
subject line to get so to explain the
answer to share information to teach
somebody a bunch of things like it
literally only has one purpose
saying that sometimes the most literal
answer
is not the best answer for like what the
subject so the subject line could say
like inside this email you're going to
learn these three things
the subject line could also say hey
h-e-y famous subject line and the reason
it was so powerful is because it was
sent from Barack Obama to his email list
and so it's just people are like dude
it's very personal like it's who was
sending it so all and it had a crazy
open rate it was only trying to do one
thing so that's when we think about okay
my thumbnail my title
is just trying to get the internet to
watch the video
so when you're like how real estate
agents can create videos easily using
chat GPT and other tools it's if you
confuse you lose I'm kind of already
it's creating a lot of friction right at
the beginning but all you what's the
purpose just so taking the analogy
what's the purpose of a title and a
thumbnail and a topic just to get
someone to click on the video now we're
not trying to trick anyone but it's
we're just trying to so it's not click
bait but we are trying to just get them
to click through
so that in the hook we could unpack
things a little bit deeper a little bit
a little bit more so then let's look
they're taking over
[Music]
welcome back to so
kind of a creative shot at doing a hook
and can you hear that okay is the volume
sound okay for you
yeah volume's good
um and so uh I I get like personal
opinion and
one creative and I'm glad you and did
the creative creativity two
I get it like it's kind of a stretch for
my mind to go okay who's they it's
probably AI it's probably whatever you
know but it was 10 seconds long
and before we're into any kind of
clarity of the next thing let's keep the
channel so if you haven't heard hey
holes are taking over
the world they're popping up everywhere
and they're taking over what I want to
talk about how real estate agents can
use these AI tools for good
but before I jump into that I just want
to remind you to hit the Subscribe
button and smash punch decompress that
Bell so that you can get notified every
time I drop a new video so let's talk
about these AI tools for just a moment
so even in your time codes and chapters
what's what's really a hard thing to
process is the idea that theoretically
this whole first minute 30 seconds is
unnecessary like we don't need to ask
for like And subscribe yet and and this
is 2023 advice we call it now the value
based hook like you asked you could ask
for that stuff at the end of the video
so the opening kind of skit could work
could work not work I oftentimes say
that like the safer play is to go
practical because comedy or humor
is a risk it's always a risk that's what
a lot of people teach you do people
understand it even comedy from different
stages it worked in one room it didn't
work in another room I'm not trying to
talk anybody out of it because if it
works it works like gangbusters but if
it doesn't work it ends up wasting time
and then you got the like it's you know
then you also like AI is generally taken
over but if you want if you think about
the audience
well yeah but like they're going to get
that information elsewhere they're maybe
they're clicking around the internet and
they're watching other things about the
good and the bad of AI but that's not
the point this whole topic could be
positioned
uh
like it could be based around a case
study like actually how one
or how I closed a deal or got more leads
how I got 30 leads in 30 days using chat
GPT like there's so many different
angles and this is the skill to master
right this is also ultimately what
through VRA and VRA Masters we want to
kind of think through is
topic
comes ahead of title and thumbnail so
even like what ultimately is it why do
you're also at a you're at a place in
the customer Journey where they already
want to create videos just chat gbt even
create videos how many AI tools so the
simplifying of
the promise the topic the title the
thumbnail and the hook and what I also
wonder is the video could theoretically
start like here
it could so let's get into it so the
first AI tool that I'll see you might
say so all right so so if you make a
really good promise and a really good um
uh title
it already told it may already frame the
context
so the first second of the video can
just start delivering
one of my favorite uh videos we call
this the value-based hook
to illustrate this is so Nolan did this
video on think media 50 YouTube video
ideas that'll blow up your channel let's
watch the beginning you could make a
perfect review video
here we go number one is a first
impressions video find something new or
trending in your space give us your
thoughts give us your first impression
that's the beginning of the video the
first line is number one is well so
let's think about this
you already know it's 50 easy YouTube
ideas you know they'll blow up your
channel thumbnail is very simple three
or less words very simple thumbnail
and you know what's actually wild about
this is what people say to the point no
fluff no long intro I got 30 replies in
1800 likes the by the way the Creator
who understands the viewer best wins now
this comes away from the real estate
agent it's just on the psychology of
online users in general like people if
the title and thumbnail is clear I know
I am here so you don't have to
necessarily restate it
so he's like number one like because
it's 50. so you know you're in the list
like not I'm Nolan not I was born in
Yakima Washington not like my favorite
you know not hit like not Iowa this like
you just and so there's still a point
where in certain content you may frame
it up you may you may need to explain
more there may be some certain things
but but the essence of everything I want
to deliver to you in that is is kind of
the funnel of I think topic could be
simplified titles could be streamlined
maybe create a little bit more mystery
or just be trimmed down a little bit
Yeah thumbnails your thumbnail creation
ability is great but but I would change
the thumbnail text the rule of three
meaning three total objects
um and
three or less words if possible no need
to Echo the the title in the thumb in
the actual thumbnail because it already
says real estate agents in 2023 so it
doesn't need to see real estate agents
again it doesn't need to say five videos
um and
and so all of that and then the last Big
Ideas we fully land the plan to get
ready for our next coaching session
session
is that
video for business owners or video for
Real Estate you need to have
self-awareness this should be
encouraging but self-awareness that your
niche
is is small anyways so you you should
it's not it's not a viral Niche that's
why vfm viral for me could be 2 000
views because if we're already a
self-aware real estate agent that wants
to make videos
then
it's such a small group of people and a
small group of people searching in a
small group of people looking for things
so
when you've dialed in your business
model lots of our students though are
cool with that because they're also like
yeah well if I do an agency or client
work I only need five clients a month so
I don't need that many views so on the
one hand that's good news but the big
idea that I'd be asking the big question
I'd be asking
is what broader appeal content could I
create
that
is still not
shifting off brand or violating my Niche
but could bring people into my world
so what's broader than video marketing
marketing
um what's broader than
literally Ai and video Marketing in
general so it could could be five
marketing Trends every real estate agent
needs to know
what's broader appeal
how
to
increase transactions in a down Market
still a marketing concept but it's just
it's now it's at a higher level because
I don't know that I need to use Ai and
use video and all this kind of stuff
down deep yet
I know that my real estate business is
suffering though and so
you know three TR like things agents do
how can I talk to agents at a macro meet
them and then they can discover how I
can help them so if so that also would
be this is why there's like two sides to
answer the public and all the tech tools
but also then sort of like the marketing
and psychology side of things in general
kind of thinking the intuition of
thinking all right
there are definitely some 10 000 even a
hundred thousand quarter million viewed
videos that I think you can create
um but if they're gonna get that many
views they're going to be broader appeal
and the benefit of that again not too
broad that like I'm just I'm just
chasing views
um but broad enough that they could
bring in a whole new flux of customers
any final follow-up questions or
thoughts on that advice
no I think I'm good I I I think I have
the the zoom call plan and the con the
feedback regarding creating mystery
utilizing the rule of three going
through my thumbnails not necessarily
matching those to the titles but really
just focusing on grabbing attention is
yeah that that's a lot to for me to kind
of walk back and and put into practice
immediately so yeah we could spend a lot
of time going deeper but this this is
good Robert I appreciate you so much and
I really want to thank you for coming on
coffee with Channel today
thanks son I appreciate it love being
here man all right take care bye
my friends that was a uh fun call and we
have dirt magicians coming up in just a
second but if you haven't smashed like
yet hit the like button and I would love
to know your aha moment that you have
already had what had did you like best
because the reason we do these also is
so you can think about what's my next
video what's my next action item what's
the next thing I need to improve on my
channel
um and be applying some of these
strategies to your own
Channel because that's our mission here
at think media is to help a million
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with YouTube
and so thinking about how you can apply
this kind of stuff and then as we get
ready after this next coaching session
throw four question marks before and
after uh questions and we'll do a little
bit of q a on the coffee with candle
show today all right I am so fired up
for our next Channel we have uh Bree and
Dee
from dirt magicians how's it going
hey good Sean I just wanted to show you
my water bottle because I know you're
all about hydration and it's full day I
think it's like four liters and it like
tells you throughout the day where you
should go like keep going just a little
bit further
so Bree you know what's so funny about
that is no joke
um I don't have that water bottle
I just ordered it what are the chances
that I ordered the exact same colorway I
don't know if you actually have the the
uh the blue like you could it's like the
blue gradient one because that's
literally the one I ordered yeah it's
like I have to order that exact same one
and oh it was it was already delivered
it is on my porch so I can finally get
hydrated I heard uh Tom Brady just spoke
in um in Miami At The Vault conference
with Patrick David and he drinks two
gallons of water a day
oh I'd probably drink a quarter gallon
of water a day and two gallons of coffee
a day
so that's why I'm dying and so I've made
a new that's why I had to get the
commitment because I want to up my uh
hydration game so that's super funny
literally the exact same colorway of
your bottle is sitting on my deck and uh
my porch but man it's so good to um meet
y'all get to hang out like this do you
want to each uh kind of break down a
little bit of the story and what you're
building and I'll pull the channel up as
well yeah sure I can I can just I can
start uh Patron MD you know Bree is a
true fan when you and her are uh aligned
in frequency I feel it I'm excited yes
um okay all right with dirt magicians
let me give you a brief background so
essentially what we've been doing
offline is that we are trying to create
communities of people that are growing
food because we ran a couple of Pilots
out here in Vancouver where we both live
and we've realized that gardeners learn
best from each other not necessarily
from influencers and we learned this by
running Pilots with people in
communities
so what we've started to do on this
channel is that we've decided that well
we need to build an audience because we
want our test we want to test some of
these ideas that we've done offline
we'll we'll need an audience that we can
basically share these ideas with and
essentially test ideas with so when we
established our YouTube channel we were
doing very general gardening education
this Channel's really been live for
about a year and a half and I think
we've been doing regular publishing
really just for the past year
um and then this year we realized we
can't just do General vegetable
gardening education because this is a
very very very crowded Niche so we said
okay how do we how do we really Niche
down and how do we focus so we
essentially started to Target beginners
more specifically and I'll let bri take
it over from here because I wanted to
give you an overview of what it is that
we're doing and then specifically with
the channel she's been taking the lead
so like let her kind of go into the
channel blueprint and how
and what we've been doing to set
ourselves apart
yeah so Sean thanks so much for for
having us on here I feel like I've been
getting to a place with our Channel
where I'm beating my head against the
wall and I'm not sure why
um so we do vegetable gardening
education
um and the way that we've tried to kind
of distinguish ourselves from other
groups and also to kind of bring this
message around community and growing
food is in a lot of the videos
um Dee is my beginner and I'm teaching
her so we kind of have back and forth
um and she asks questions
um and then we've had one video that we
honestly like threw together last year
right when we were starting
um that went viral for us we had like a
hundred thousand views and it was just
eight DIY trellis ideas from other
gardeners so we've been trying
to replicate that and just going into
because we did these Pilots we have a
bunch of gardeners who will let us kind
of creep into their backyards and
um you know show what they're doing so
we've got a few videos on that and then
again because we're doing this offline
Garden education
um we've taken real questions from
gardeners in those education sessions
that various gardeners have done and
then we just make a Youtube video
um about that and you know I've been
going through VRA I do you know uh
YouTube autofill vid IQ we look at
competitors we look at top videos for
topic research I have a bunch of
questions that I answer before I even
start scripting but I think one of our
big challenges is just getting people to
stick through the video
um we still seem to have even though we
felt like we've shortened intros and I
think part of it is you know when you're
so into what you're doing like I watch a
video that's been fully edited and I'm
like oh this looks great people are
gonna love this and then we still end up
with like 25 to 40 retention so we're
just not sure how to increase retention
on our videos
great and then
before we dive into that and we can look
at a video what did you learn why do you
think this video did so well
um well we we initially thought a
trellising usually does really well in
gardening videos we've learned from just
like looking at other competitors
um and then the other piece was uh we
thought sort of showing what you can do
in other Gardens and kind of like
getting to peek into other people's
yards
um but that hasn't translated as much
yet this year but then on the other hand
this video didn't do well in the first
week or two and then the algorithm
picked it up probably like a month or
two later
what
did you try to do other lists listicles
um yeah so we've done like four ways to
grow potatoes five ways to Trellis
cucumbers four ways to start a vegetable
garden
because what I also wonder but I'm also
thinking like um
the insights from this for me is that
it's like a specific
pain Point desire that gardeners want
and then it educates on multiple ways to
do it so
I don't know anything but an idea for me
would be like raised beds
what if it was like
you know six different styles of raised
beds and then play that out this is a
common thing that a lot of you channels
find too like a lot of channels will
find almost like a template but I don't
think it's four easy ways to start a
garden I think it's I think what you
found here like one of the things we
found would be clusters of tech and uh
Tech channels figured out that
accessories under fifty dollars because
it's like a format where people like
okay I know I would love to up my Tech
game my content creation game under
fifty dollars so if it was trellises a
certain thing and maybe you don't do
vertical gardening but if it's vertical
and ways to do it is speaks to
um you know or DIY DIY too because that
would sort of mean right like not
pre-packaged but like somebody could
follow along and then by the end of the
video they have a huge payoff because
they're like oh that would work in my
space based in my amount of any thoughts
on that does that seem like a cool
way to maybe double down and try success
leaves Clues make part twos
yeah we did try to do some DIY building
trellis ones although I know for one of
them I think uh we're still learning how
to use a camera this year we were all
iPhone last year uh so the visual wasn't
great and then I think also we had a
really long intro so it didn't do
um as well but yeah I think definitely
the DIY follow-up what do you think
about like raised garden beds like these
ideas have you like hit these just
curious just asking questions yeah so
we've done on yeah I think we did more
specifically garden designs not raised
bed
cool so so I mean that's an idea like
back to
you're using all the tools it's great
you're you know you're using that IQ
you're using all the stuff but back to
like topic being the first ingredient
the big idea of the perfect video recipe
is like the topic itself
um sometimes having a breakout topic
could be taking something whether it's
right you know and whatever other things
that there are like that certain
of course there's trends that happen
um as well and and Trends would be maybe
seasonal I guess you said uh
yeah okay you know I don't know what
else is there besides trellises and
raised guard beds and greenhouses and
and like just to maybe these things like
this desire that a lot of America maybe
to somebody in their backyard in Canada
would want to and international
um okay and then let's dive into uh a
video and see what we could learn here
we're going to help you create a drop
different person we've had a few guests
video people people come in can I do
this one the cucumber yeah that's a good
one hey dirt magicians trellis and
cucumbers is a great way to increase the
vertical growing space in your garden
which leaves you more space to grow not
only more cucumbers but also other
vegetables now there are two factors we
need to meet when we're coming up with
something this is a personal
um preference and just uh
one one of my in a way pet peeves I
talked to our team about this when we're
doing time codes and chapters I hate the
word intro
like the word intro
to me is irrelevant
here's why I also think that what does
it say on Netflix when you're watching a
show there's actually a hook
then there's
the intro and it says skip intro and
besides the one percent of people
watching this that play that thing I
mean maybe you watch it the first time
because you're like let me get a Vibe
for like the show intro with the music
and the credits what do people click
skip intro skip intro skip the credits
move to the next thing so even just the
psychology of an intro now what we would
say is we just name it something
different we might say I might name it
two factors because now I want to create
desire like two factors you need to know
because I need to watch that part
otherwise I could just skip to here and
actually get into
what you've potentially promised now if
you're also going to say five DIY
trellis ideas well I just want to skip
to the first trellis idea so you like
how quickly can you get to it so anyways
just personal pet peeve it's a small
thing there's obviously the video
architecture itself but titling a
chapter intro in my personal opinion is
kind of pointless kind of support
there are some things
fire or string that the Cucumbers can
grab onto as they have these little
tendrils and two it needs to be strong
enough to be able to support multiple
fruits per cucumber plant so if you can
meet those conditions there are so many
different ways to Charles cucumbers so
in this video we are going to show you
five different ways that you can trellis
cucumbers here in groveville I mean at
the end of the day I don't I wouldn't
think your your view duration is not
probably uncommon
um
for this kind of information people
whether they want to stick with it or
not you know whether that what I would
go in are you studying your audience
retention curve
uh for the first yes
because are you seeing spikes like
little blips at the chapters
uh yeah sometimes because that's also
just it's sort of the that that kind of
helps you see inside of the viewer
experience
like they actually don't
like I love chapters some people argue
don't use them
but one person could click on this video
and be like okay there's a tomato cage
trellis I already know about that Garden
six trellis I'm not gonna use that one
okay I do want to watch the triangle
trellis they watch it for a little while
and they're like okay I got the idea my
neighbor does that string chalice I
would never do that and DIY Archway okay
let me watch that one like just the idea
like they you are kind of which I think
it's valuable I just want to give the
viewer value so they could skip around
um but that's something to kind of study
to see where people are being led around
the only other thought up here is trying
to like raise the stakes
and articulate and give people a
personal a reason to watch till the end
now I could see your Vibe very centered
clear articulating well
no weird energy YouTube energy that's
all
100 miles per hour Mr B style you're not
yelling at anybody
I see all that like
however I think that in your style
um the problem we want to solve is
gaining the viewers the viewers
attention and giving them a reason to
watch until the end
like as much as possible if we can
articulate or preview
and back to our last conversation if
someone's watching this full coffee with
piano episode on replay
if you think about everything being a
progressive like what I do know for sure
is you're going to teach me or at least
I hope you're going to teach me five DIY
cucumber trellis ideas from other
gardeners
okay
um it also probably I'll come back to
that I don't think it even needs to say
other gardeners because who cares where
they're from I just want the ideas and
less is more
um and if we though if you grip me
on
the the thumbnail you grip me with the
idea but now once I'm inside what's the
point of an email subject line get
people to open the email what's the
point of a Yelp listing for a restaurant
get someone to actually show up to the
restaurant once they're in the
restaurant we use this in the perfect
video recipe in YouTube Secrets when I
explain it it's also like each piece is
meant to just get you in the door but
then the food has got to be good and
once the food is good you also hope the
service is good but the ultimate goal is
not just to get someone in the door
eating at the restaurant the ultimate
goal is Word of Mouth get someone to
coming back uh and and tell their
friends and leave a review and actually
have a repeat customer repeat business
which would be the conversion of a
subscriber but not just a subscriber it
would be somebody who actually had an
experience with dirt magicians and it's
like I love their videos I can't miss
their videos tall order like but that's
the dream the dream would be someone
clicks on one of your videos discovers
you follows you loves you and watches
every second of your content till the
end of time that would be Perfection of
what we're trying to accomplish on
YouTube so saying that all you're trying
to do is get them into the video but
then it's like how could we
give them some other bonuses they know
they're going to get these cucumber
trellises but the things that are top of
Mind are also some of the mistakes that
people make and I'm going to be sharing
with you a story of one person who was
able to double their Harvest like double
their crop because they made this tweak
to one of their trellises
um and also and you maybe not you don't
do all of this but these are like the
different Frameworks you could use I'm
obviously be sharing like a mistake that
when if you actually set this up wrong
um it ends up sucking the life out of
your plants and and so
I'm in it I'm already there you're not
trying to be really long-winded and like
make up all the stuff of reason to watch
because you want to try to architecture
content in such a way that you're
re-engaging the viewer so that there's a
reason to watch to the end or a reason
to watch through the different segments
any feedback on that
question Sean so if you were to set that
up and say okay you know at some point
maybe in the very you say I'll give you
the five DIY trellis ideas but I'll also
tell you one way you could build these
trellises that's going to screw up your
priorities or something like that where
you embed something like that to
re-engage them because obviously they're
skipping around based on the chapters
because they want to get to that trellis
but then you don't want to embed that as
a chapter do you because you want to
bury it somewhere so people are looking
for it like how like how do you use that
yeah you that that's that's up to you
and those mistake you might not say when
the mistake is the mistake could be
taught during anything and maybe it's
not an entire it's just you get this one
you get this one but mid Midway through
here is that this is also why in video
ranking Academy the 7rs are in the order
that they're in because if you have
reverse engineered the thumbnail the
title all this different stuff you've
done your research you've done your um
and then also in research would be
pre-record is outlining the video before
we record we think about okay big idea
you know trellis one trellis two trellis
three how can we spice this up
one of the big mistakes people make on
Trellis 3 or
it could be in a chance for say
affiliate marketing or something you
know that when it comes to that third
trellis
there's that new irrigation thing that's
two bucks on Amazon like if you get that
like so it also it's not just a mistake
or something that'll hurt it's something
that will power up your thing this brand
new type of rope that is better that's
biodegradable like just thinking about
enhancement so if we
pre-plan if we fail to plan we plan to
fail but prior planning prevents poor
performance and by looking at our
outline how could we spice this up
what's a mistake what's a bonus what's
something else we could include and then
you can include it anywhere another
thought on these time codes and chapters
too I think for search based
I like that you're saying what it is
uh but there's another strategy in in
time codes and chapters and the reason I
say for search Bases theoretically
somebody that's looking up triangle
trellis this could rank kind of on
Google theoretic like there's like key
moments so that could actually show up
on Google alternatively though for
mystery we'll sometimes say trellis one
trellis two trellis three trellis four
trellis five which is another way to
think about like its organization so
people can skip around but they at least
need to
and and someone might say well that's
less value to be sure but you also made
this incredible free content and they at
least can get the big idea of each one
and and and and and it's gonna actually
probably increase if they're sold on the
concept it would increase average view
duration because it'll give each one 10
or 20 seconds and maybe the one they're
interested in to watch the whole segment
just another thing and these are things
we're always testing and and uh and
playing with but any feedback on that
yeah I know that's really helpful and it
actually
um I'm outlining a video right now and
it just gave me a great idea of how to
to hook somebody with a wait until we
share
um you know something that will fail if
you do this kind of thing so I think the
other thing that can like let's power up
the hook more the other thing to power
up the hook is to tr is to try
like what I would love to see is to show
all five in b-roll
so as you're saying it you show a
panning shot of one a panning shot of
other now the way this looks to me is a
little tough because with the nature of
the leafy plants and maybe kind of how
busy it looks
and even if it didn't like but like this
so like if you showed me that
and if it if it said even trellis number
one over top or if it if it had some
mystery to it
um what the goal and this is what a new
reality TV show does or and it's what
top YouTubers do as well they actually
kind of tease
the juiciest shots coming later in the
video this subject matter isn't the
juiciest subject matter like oh my gosh
like look at this trellis but like
nevertheless
um it it still
is reinforcing the art what you're
articulating too so so if it's also like
here's you're gonna get these practical
five things you're also gonna get this
really cool thing and what they'll
sometimes do is blur it out
it's it's good like to blur it out like
this cool I'm also gonna be revealing
like this really cool trick that we
found that like doubled
um and two
um uh garden tools that that we have
absolutely been loving and that's you
don't have to force
any of this stuff into the video but any
any these are all in enhancements that
could lead to best practice
of improving it and then you know the
final thing I would say would be
back to just big idea like let's zoom
out and say okay
um
I don't love
the thumbnail
you're kind of small here yes you've
sort of
grayed out
you know one thing that I would
potentially do and this is because of
the nature of a busy Garden leafy things
is I I wonder if I'd get like a cloth
and and you could potentially and or a
good DSLR mirrorless camera
to try to get like isolated shots of
things
um so let me think about let's see if we
just go trellis ideas and we'll see like
what's ranked
and see what we can see how that's
pretty that's clear because the most top
ranked video is
not a great thumbnail but it's
incredibly clear
um
this is pretty amazing and and what I
guess that's what I mean by the cloth is
the the greenhouse there puts Simplicity
behind what it is it makes it a little
sharper this is also clear because of
the dark trees this is clear because of
the zoom in
um and so hey dirt magician you have
your work cut out for you but I guess
and forgive me this is just my feedback
but that's great but
but this doesn't even look like a
trellis to me like I don't know even
know what I'm looking at so the
thumbnail is kind of confusing
ultimately it's sort of like okay
there's I sort of see okay so I see that
trellis you also say so many cucumber
ideas I don't see any cucumbers I mean
kind of one but it's in the shadow
lighting time of day it's tough so you
like harsh sunlight sun is Right Above
This is dark these leaves are bright
harsh Shadows light Dynamics
you're tiny over here there's the cut
out what are we looking at what's the
Cucumber idea this is pointing to the
flowers the Cucumbers down I could
barely and I'm never gonna look at it as
large as we're looking at it it's on a
smartphone and
and I guess okay so it's cucumber
trellis ideas that makes sense so so
many cucumber ideas but what even is a
cucumber idea is that actually the
desire of the viewer is
is is trellis ideas
and if it was
um unique two words like unique trellis
or like uh and I don't love that but
it's you know something different like
you gotta see this
um try this like sometimes those are my
favorite words it just says try this and
it points to something that looks
interesting and that's somewhat clear
so I think that and then try this is
just try what eye-catching thumbnail now
I read the title and then five DIY
cucumber trellis ideas
there's something super powerful about
really short incredibly clear titles so
the whole from other gardeners is
unnecessary in my opinion I think what's
interesting is it could be five DIY
cucumber trellis ideas and there's a lot
of other ways you could power that up as
well it could be like five DIY cucumber
trellis ideas
fill that either it's usually more
benefit or like removal of pain
um DIY you know that you could build for
free for free under a hundred dollars
and I know this might not be relevant
here but just in general you know
um that are easy to set up but I don't
even think it actually needs anything I
don't understand if it was also if there
was a genuine benefit of other gardeners
then maybe the thumbnail is three
distinct kind of like decent photos of
you know diverse looking gardeners
because that's the value proposition and
like oh cool I want I want to actually
hear different people's perspective but
to me other gardeners
the promise is just the ideas what am I
here for just cucumber trellis ideas and
I'm you know wanting to find that any uh
feedback or things you want to process
that we've been talking about
no that's that's really helpful
um and honestly they're from other
gardeners we pulled just because that
was on our previous trellis video so
we're like well it worked here so we'll
try it here but uh no I think just even
hearing your thought process around you
know what's the value what are the key
pieces that people care for
um yeah it was really helpful
and then success leaves Clues so
so um okay naturally this channel has
got more subs so that's an advantage
however it's always this huge signal
when someone has more views than they do
subscribers on a video the video is a
year old it's done very very well and
this I think is a picture of some of the
things I would hope to achieve yeah one
um still he's kind of a little small and
dimly lit but the thumbnail is pretty
great what's the desire a cucumber
trellis that's exactly what I want like
that's what I'm on YouTube for so that's
clear it's zoomed in the Cucumbers
interesting like if this is good
psychology conversation I love this
stuff
does we think about what like features
and benefits
what is that that people ultimately
desire do people ultimately desire a
trellis or do they desire a delicious
cucumber yeah you know what does people
ultimately desire like power windows or
being cool in the car and so even the
trellis is a means to an end if we also
think about viewer Behavior so even even
the payoff those cucumbers look amazing
he's also he's also taking the photo in
overcast uh lighting making it much more
easy for cameras to expose properly the
greens are rich and we could take this
thumbnail and make it a lot better if he
was lit better you could see the whites
of his eyes and even maybe a little bit
more vibrancy
um saturation because
uh yes I'm looking for the Practical
tool to get me to my desired destination
which is delicious giant cucumbers great
and then look at how great the title is
so use this cucumber trellis for a huge
Harvest features and benefits in the
title and so
um you think about you you know five DIY
trellis ideas
for doubling your Harvest for a huge
Harvest now that could be click bait so
you want to be honest
um but that is
one of those things if we look at just
the concept itself and if you're
brainstorming ideas to your point us
processing together is why we want to do
um you know coaching sessions like this
on coffee with candle is before we press
record
I would want to have this conversation
even if it's just with myself
I'm looking at other videos I'm opening
up vid IQ I'm opening up
um and I'm reminding myself to go
through the 7rs and I want to work the
system because
once we get clear on some of these ideas
even how we hook the video what we say
in the hook is influenced and it's going
to influence everything down the the
chain
um and thus it can lead us to an
opportunity like this would be a viral
for vfm if if you all got another 100K
another 200k and all of that's in your
future you're going to be you know
crushing it as you continue to do that
another thing I notice here
is again overcast lighting that trellis
looks super cool it's very distinct to
see what it is you know
um it's interesting it's kind of a nice
shot it's got a nice smile happy the
angle of the shot happens to be on
darker trees behind allowing the white
fish line or thread or whatever to kind
of show up this one is super good
because of the kind of symmetricy and
the wide angle shot so
I hope that some of these thoughts that
one's super good it is green on green on
green on green so I almost wonder like
what if you dropped a a white piece of
plastic behind that and that goes into
the idea of just this Factor like this
is ridiculous you're like saying we
should take 20 minutes if so and like
someone stands on a ladder and holds up
a couple different you know sheets we
bring from home in order and then take
different thumbnail photography yeah I I
am actually because like taking that
much more time this one is good too you
got the depth of field meaning the
blurriness the white on him kind of Pops
him a little bit more but it's very
clear and sturdy and cheap being
different language pointing to a desire
of that particular uh trellis that we
could ultimately apply there as well so
I think a lot of that some super
tactical stuff for some of your future
videos hit me with any final questions
or uh feedback on on some of those tips
uh I mean for me that was really helpful
uh and I totally hear you on the sheet
they're the number of times that we
shoot stuff and we're like this is
ridiculous like I'll be behind her with
a light like this and so uh adding a
sheet into the mixes it will not be new
for us that's a great idea actually
because we do sometimes struggle we're
like oh you can't really see what we're
trying to to show here so
um yeah that was really helpful thank
you so much for kind of going through
that and it's it's really helpful to
just have outside eyes because sometimes
you just get so into the thick of it and
D I'll cover you in just a second but I
also
um want to
encourage that sometimes and you're
already doing that I can see you're
probably pulling stock photos maybe of
these strawberries and whatnot I I want
everybody listening to this
to when you're conceptualizing a
thumbnail I think ethically it is okay
to Stage something that isn't the exact
thing so long as it's still honest so in
some cases
isolating what it is using stock photos
or whatever we're just trying to tell
the best story that's honest that
communicates what it is we're trying to
show and that's in some environments so
we struggle with this with for example
with desk setups because the nature of
like a full-on desk setup is not
necessarily conducive to a thumbnail
because zoomed out two monitors all
these cables and whatever else it's like
how do you show that so it's the big
question content creators want to ask is
like what are the ways to show one time
we did an entire audio video lighting
setup for like a church
and the thumbnail ended up being three
panels of a very isolated microphone of
an isolated camera but because to zoom
out and show like the whole room and all
the chairs and the weird lighting and so
on it just it just is not conducive so
it's kind of asking ourselves
okay I really love yours and it's a big
viewed video I love your don't do this
do this that that kind of concept is is
so great the title could probably be a
little bit better like organic
fertilizers how to fertilize your garden
without chemicals like the this organic
fertilizer will kill your garden
dot dot dot
that so then like okay and begin and
we're we we hold intention in VRA search
based practical that's just like a great
title search base the way you wrote it
but the way your thumbnail was gives it
the opportunity to kind of be like a
little viral video within your community
of everyone being like wait a minute I
don't want to kill my garden just did
the other angle so it's the we do both
we do search based rule practical titles
and then we do that like
you know this cucumber trellis will give
you a huge Harvest what cucumber trellis
the nice thing about that is it's both
it's VRA cucumber trellis could be a
search based thing that may rank that
video but it also has mystery around it
as opposed to like the entire child
title revealing the video
okay D any final questions any thoughts
no I think it was really good because I
think this year we finally invested in a
camera and we started finding the right
times to shoot so things weren't blown
out because even the overhead sun
because we realized you know if we shoot
just between this time and this time
everything's getting blown out so I
think having the discipline to even
shoot the thumbnail because you know one
of the things we've tried to do is let's
not make the thumbnail the afterthought
but the thumbnail during the shoot is
always till the afterthought and it's
showing uh so I think even as you were
critiquing it I was thinking okay we
really got to make this a priority we
gotta shoot it at a time when it's not
we know for a fact it's not going to get
blown out and then thinking of all the
other elements because the green on
green
yeah I mean it makes sense it's just too
crowded it's too busy so that was really
valuable Sean thanks
and I've got one piece of tech for
you to add it's very cheap to add to
your
repertoire we'll link this up in the
description of course but in your
specific situation do you have one of
these
uh a three a five in one reflector dish
no
okay so if I'm you I want the largest
reflector dish because you're at the
you're in these outdoor situations but
watch this this is going to be like the
coolest asset so 24 inches 43 inches
um
okay so 42 I liked on B H Photo this one
we found is
40. so 42 is great let's see was there a
42 here and then I'll explain what we're
looking at
so what's gonna be amazing with this
reflector dish is number one
you can go white so it'll just kind of
be subtle and it can Splat so you could
you you could redirect the sun to
overcompensate From Shadows and like
make a plant glow like so now and you
could you could shine it with the silver
reflection or the gold
uh black to block light from one side or
whatever and perhaps throw this even you
could also put this behind the object so
just a little tool kind of like a sheet
42 inches is pretty big but the other uh
option is see how one is is clear is you
you put it up in the air the sun is
direct and it'll Shadow the object down
below and maybe the fence is behind it
so you could just have you could buy one
or two of these 23 dollars so you like
and they fold up although that's impo
that's like the joke is like how hard
you're like trying to get it back into
its case you can never get into its case
again uh but but no this this is this
would be super for being an outdoor
photography situation you could shine
the light on it uh you know put
something behind it and then ultimately
and film sets they'll use these c-stands
and have giant
um
scrim or sheets or filters that they'll
put above two people talking and it
could be 20 feet by 20 feet and they'll
stretch it above to be able to basically
create an overcast situation and so the
cool thing here is you could put a
diffused lighting
um you struggle with lighting uh
ultimately
above your yes it goes down nice little
small case there and
this one's probably great but what I I
have one at our Vegas office
I don't know how big 42 inches that's
giant it's like unreasonably large
but perfect for your situation if you
had like a bed of of you know plants you
wanted to end up and then and then snap
snaps that snap and take it back and
once you're looking at all the photos
you're like that one looks really good
and that would be a huge asset that only
cost a few dollars
awesome yeah okay hey appreciate you all
so much thank you for being a part of uh
coffee with candle today yeah I think
all right appreciate y'all take care
okay coffee with candle listen we're
about to do some q a uh it looks like JP
just dropped a link to um one of these
uh
variable filters that could be something
cool that you might want to check out if
you haven't smashed the like button
smash the like button and if you haven't
um
dropped any aha moments dropping aha
moment we're talking about titles
thumbnails topics research Hooks and
watch the replay of this episode we get
really granular and tactical on coffee
with candle out here today
um let me know what you're drinking I'm
sipping on some Ethiopian yoga Chef uh
single origin and uh it's delicious and
I'm going to jump into your questions
here in just a second
but I do want to encourage you when it
comes to some of these
um
titles
video ideas
thumbnail templates if you're interested
in all that kind of stuff and you've
never picked up our YouTube starter kit
it'll help you go really fast and uh
it's super affordable check this out
this video is brought to you by YouTube
starter kit dot com download your power
packed digital asset bundle today to
dramatically shortcut the path to
creating or Reviving your YouTube
channel inside you'll get access to our
AI for YouTube guide video checklists
title formulas thumbnail templates and
our 51 money making ideas download and
so much more to download these resources
and to start growing your YouTube
channel faster just go to
tubestarterkit.com
thank you
welcome back to coffee with Channel
tubestarterkit.com this is one of the
coolest things we've ever created here
at think media there's so many valuable
resources and this product has gone on
different sales over the years I think
yeah right now it's just forty seven
dollars tube starter kit.com
um and you've got it actually was
completely rebuilt recently and so uh
the think media team and I uh getting
our Clarity blueprints you get super
clear 51 money making video ideas create
awesome thumbnails a lot of really cool
stuff in there
um to check out and the fact we're
including our AI guide is crazy I didn't
even know that so that was a really
great resource that we've been working
on lately and so anyways check that out
that is uh tube starter kit.com
and let me jump into some of your
questions and I wanted to see if you
have any aha moments we got we got water
in the house smart T in the house
uh JP's asking are those resources
already in VRA starter kit is separate
to VRA and so I don't believe the
thumbnail templates are in there I don't
believe the title formulas are in there
now in VRA
you learn how to develop titles at a
Mastery level but this set of checklists
um is uh is different than what's inside
of VRA there is a little bit of overlap
like you do have the 51 money making
video ideas but we have this thing
priced at such a level that
um it is a great resource every once in
a while then and you'll probably notice
if you hang out with us that when we
have web classes and stuff we do special
offers and our bonuses
like at the end of a class I'll talk
about VRA and there's like other bonuses
those do change so those change
sometimes you get the starter kit
sometimes you don't and we are always
just wanting to be honest and clear with
our deadlines and all of that stuff and
so every once in a while you do have a
chance to get it when you join VRA so
you can always check your members area
to see there uh to see if it's there
um but JP I'm not sure when you join too
the cool thing lately is that people are
still getting lifetime access that's
going away pretty soon to our video
record Academy program so some people
joined a year and a half ago and AI guy
didn't exist yet and different things
didn't exist and so you can always
purchase those things separately but if
you don't have the starter kit in your
members area 47 that's like skipping one
eating out
and then making a video that's going to
pay you for the next six years and eat
out as much as you want so I think that
uh some definitely a valuable resource
you can check out
drinking some good old H2O we got
Jamaican soda I've never had that that
sounds uh delicious and uh let's dive
into some q a for the coffee with candle
show today let me also look at my
calendar and look if I'm about to
make Kyle mad or somebody I don't know
who's who's mad at me I have plenty of
time I'm still within my allotted coffee
with candle window and so we have some
chants for some q a today how do I help
my longer videos get more views compared
to my shorts I would encourage you to
re-watch this training if you've been
here the whole time we shared those
tactics better hook
try not to over explain you know one
thing that's powerful is if you do
outline your video and if you script
your video like I don't really script my
videos but I would say try to speak at a
fifth grade reading level
when you become an expert on something
um
what happens is
you lose touch with someone that's just
getting started and you might speak at a
pace and speak at language that's hard
to follow and how hard to kind of retain
the viewer so there's a lot of best
practices
understanding who the video is made for
let's look at it from this perspective
what could cause somebody to jump off of
a video
over explaining this is getting boring I
want to leave
being hard to understand
I'm having trouble following this person
like I just I don't get it I don't know
I'm gonna go look for somebody that can
explain it clearer simpler
boring maybe the energy is low and it's
too monotonous
um so maybe injecting in just some
pattern resets
um something that makes the video a
little bit more interesting
being too in like funny or making jokes
we talked about that earlier like
putting in lots of humor and lots of
like bro get to the point like keep
sharing the main content like I get
there's all these like side jokes but
I'm just trying to get the information
so I'm not trying to overwhelm you or
anybody but it's a delicate dance we're
just trying to think about your video
having a pace
a pace of editing a pace of
the information a pace of and and maybe
one of the most powerful communication
tools though I could say is when I also
think about pace is you know a spoonful
of sugar helps the medicine go down
what when did Sean become Mary Poppins
like if you're this would be for
Education channels
if you are teaching something that's
like bro give me a break and there's
it's like it's hard to learn you know
I'm teaching I've been doing video for
20 years in YouTube for 16.
it's really easy for me to overwhelm
people you're like I know I'm already
overwhelmed so it's really easy so if if
I try to maybe slow down tell a story
facts tell but stories sell
so you make a point but illustrate it
with the story oh now it's making sense
this would all be like the art of
communication
and so a spoonful of sugar helps the
medicine go down it's like okay the
medicine is like they're coming here to
learn something
to discover something but it's so boring
like this is medicine yuck
well A Spoonful of Sugar Sugar could
just be a story a joke entertainment of
some kind a pattern reset change of
scenery something that's sweet that
improves the thing that I want to
ultimately the result I want to give if
anything we could call this edutainment
too that education is good and
entertainment is good but the best
things educational channels can do is
think about how can I make this content
a little bit more entertaining and
that's always good to hold viewer
retention how can you tell when the
season is passed for seasonal content
dhn crypto what a great question
so let's talk about
tent poles
and the cool thing about this is
the tool is going to be Google
trends
so dhn crypto asks how can you tell when
a season is passed for seasonal content
well my tip for you is first of all
let's go to Google Trends
and let's look up Thanksgiving
so we're gonna go Thanksgiving on Google
Trends as a search term now if you were
a
DIY channel home decor
Food Channel Cooking Channel or anything
else that might relate to Thanksgiving
content
this would be kind of relevant for you
and you could do this with anything that
you're using so what we're gonna any any
Niche and you could change the topic out
we're going to switch from web search to
YouTube search
and we're gonna go to
the
past
12 months
and what we're going to do here is see
that interest in Thanksgiving is at an
all-time low right now which makes sense
as of mid-september here beginning of
September so let's look back to last
year and this right here is how is what
can influence your content creation
schedule meaning this as you're planning
ahead and you start thinking okay
I'm going to operate here as a again
home decor or cooking uh
turkey recipe Thanksgiving turkey recipe
vegan recipe you just tap it into some
Trends uh paleo friendly uh Thanksgiving
meal prep you know whatever uh
Thanksgiving table Decor Etc so you ask
your the question is when should I
release the video like because timing
matters when and the reason these are
called tentpoles tentpole events are the
Super Bowl Thanksgiving is because it's
it's look it's like a tent you could
live inside of there like it comes up it
comes down
and so there are these Peaks where it
would be really foolish to release a
Thanksgiving Video in April
it would be really smart to release it
at a strategic time tadpoles could be
Comic Con tent poles could be Christmas
tent poles could be the Super Bowl 10
bowls could be Niche events that happen
annually in subcultures so let's let's
look the
you could release the video
as early as October 30th
and you'll notice that that's it's still
on the rise and there is more interest
and the cool thing about YouTube is you
may get the benefit of this entire climb
of traffic right here
um I would say that based on this
November 6th is where it starts to Peak
if I was going to make something about
Thanksgiving
November 6 would be the time to do it
that happens to be my birthday I turned
40. uh this year and so then I'm going
to get the whole benefit of that Peak
now here's what's also interesting is
you also get the you get quite a bit of
traffic all the way until or you get
interest all the way until December 3rd
so it goes past the event we found that
to be true it always shocks me I do
Black Friday videos every single day
every single day every single year for
the past
that's my whole life the past five ten
years
and it's but the Black Friday Peak is
like Black Friday itself between
November 20th and the 26th usually the
day after Thanksgiving which I think is
November 25th but notice that there's
still traffic that comes that goes all
the way until December 10th and I've
noticed that to be true I'm like it's
over but it's maybe because
I make a list of the best deals and
people are just curious I don't know I
don't know I'm speculating I all I know
is the videos keep getting views for
like a couple more weeks so
you're
you know
worst case scenario you're like oh shoot
I missed it but you could still release
the video
it'd be kind of weird to do a Black
Friday video after Black Friday but you
could still have some benefit if you
went the 27th or something
um
it would be
obviously too late once you find
yourself here in early December or at
any other time of the year
and you'll also notice why some channels
May if there is any pre-information on
articles or something we'll do like
Black Friday stuff a little bit earlier
so the tool is called Google Trends it's
it's free to use
um you could switch it to YouTube search
you also it's also incredibly powerful
for maybe comparing two different things
you should uh you know am I gonna do a
Black Friday video or Thanksgiving Video
which is going to get more search well
Thanksgiving is way bigger than Black
Friday in and of itself however like
what does that mean why are people
searching maybe you were thinking am I
going to create a Call of Duty gaming
series next or a uh Last of Us uh gaming
series oh this will be this will be
messed up because people are looking at
the HBO show but nevertheless look at
some of this stuff right you you can now
compare different things and compare
Last of Us this probably was peaking
during the show I'm guessing and now
it's kind of died off and Call of Duty
is more popular and so maybe you want to
have a more Niche series maybe you want
to tap into a thing that's more popular
obviously I understand that you could do
Vanguard and a million other
distinctions but understanding how to
use Google Trends is one of the most
powerful tools to have in your tool belt
that is one thing that we just one of
the many tools we talk about like in our
video ranking Academy program when you
can understand all the tools and blend
them together because I've learned that
no one tool really reveals all the
information but the most dangerous
content creator is the content creator
that's like let's check out Google
Trends let's check out vid IQ let's do
some keyword research let's let's talk
to let me shoot an email to my community
let me let me talk to somebody or I've
had feedback I've been reading my
comments
um
there's the idea that's the positioning
of the idea based on the combination of
multiple tools and um
and it's too late
when you're on the other side of the
tent pole and too many people I think
missed the rise because you want all the
benefit of the rise of the trend
man who likes that tip cardboard guide
says great tips on Google Trends I love
it
um
uh Corky how can I get info on the elite
group we did just launch a new thing
called VRA Elite that means you get
hooked up with the think media certified
coach
um and we kind of walk with you it's
kind of like having a personal trainer
like we could give you access to the
course where you could do it yourself at
your own pace
going through the content at your own
pace that's called VRA VRA Elite is like
okay let me we don't just have the
course material that you can take on
your phone the laptop or course video
ranking Academy but I want to get a
certified coach to give me feedback and
accountability
personal trainer are you doing your
workouts I've been going through the
material do you understand it
why am I looking at your thumbnails and
you're not doing what Sean said
yeah it's super powerful and so
um it should be in your uh quirky email
it's also in the VRA Facebook group if
you haven't been in there and if you're
getting emails from VRA and I think uh
Drea can drop you a link as well
um to we don't have like a really good
page built out for it but it is on
special discount right now
um and
that is uh
it's like 50 off of what it's going to
be as we're launching kind of the
Genesis of VR ale we're so excited
there's already like 30 people that
signed up
okay
um I got a couple more questions coming
your way here in just a second but I
want to remind you every single Tuesday
and Thursday
something special happens right here on
YouTube on the think media podcast
Channel but also on Spotify and apple
check this out did you know that we have
a weekly show called The think media
podcast if you want to learn the best
strategies for growing your business and
brand with YouTube for how to thrive as
a Creator or how to get more leads and
clients and customers as an entrepreneur
and I want to invite you to subscribe to
the think media podcast available on
YouTube and all of the audio platforms
on this show you're gonna find Advanced
strategies for understanding YouTube for
building the business mechanics around
your YouTube channel including your
email list or taking what you know and
turning it into profitable products we
have amazing guest interviews and all
kinds of special surprises that happen
consistently on the think media podcast
so to get access for free just click the
link in the description or go to
thinkmediapodcast.com
welcome back to coffee with Channel
listen I know that I'm probably
preaching to the choir here because
we're on the think media podcast channel
so we do release our main podcast on
this channel this live stream this show
is where we do coaching
um with
um our students and where we also answer
your questions and where we drink coffee
or water or Jamaican soda but our think
media podcast
um is one of our favorite things to
create and uh here's a couple reviews on
Apple a great communicator adds value
support this channel I think media
supports your every step of the way
adding value to the industry really
enjoy this podcast found some insightful
Concepts that helped me along the
journey
if you are a fan of the think media
podcast would you consider doing me a
favor literally there's 113 people here
live and uh I know you might watch on
YouTube but if you have the podcast app
on your phone
whether you Spotify or apple if you
would consider to take a second even
while you're watching this why I'm doing
Q a and leave a review you could leave a
text review or just a star rating review
that would mean the world to me and so
it's the think media podcast a lot of
people do like to listen to it on audio
when they're walking their dog sipping
iced tea on the golf course when they're
at the gym when they're in traffic in
Southern California or in Michigan
or Chicago
um what what is your formula for coming
up with cities I don't know I'm just
it's just Kansas
um Toronto Canada so whether you're just
on the road listening it's always great
to listen on audio but it would you
would you consider doing that type yes
in the comments you could say yes Sean I
would love to leave a review
um on either Spotify or apple of course
apple is sort of like the A Home of cod
podcast the Genesis of podcasts
ironically it's not even the biggest pop
podcast platform did you know that
YouTube is the biggest plot podcast
platform that more listeners consume
podcast content on YouTube than on any
other platform
nevertheless I'm pleading with you for
uh leaving a review on one of the audio
platforms because we are publishing it
everywhere and uh and we thank you yes
oh y'all y'all are it seriously does
mean the world to me we put a ton of
work into the podcast I was just talking
with Kyle Anderson our uh the head of
think media our creative director and
the lead tech
crispy connoisseur
of producing the episodes that we filmed
in Vegas when um I'm in Vegas listen
let's do some rapid fire questions here
is making news-like information
not Evergreen video a waste of time I
come from the VR Tech news space it's
what I know challenge is applying think
media techniques to that content
show I appreciate the question
um number one
it's not a waste of time at all number
two
it's one of our think media techniques
actually so I I respect I know we we hit
search based Evergreen content so hard
I respect you saying that's not one of
our techniques however I'm not sure if
you're part of era or not inside of VRA
Masters we talk about 16 different
techniques that we teach at think media
we're probably most known for
search-based ranked videos
um but Trend surfing influence surfing
is 100 one of our primary techniques I
think the most
dangerous content creators they don't
just use one tool to use many so I think
a good content catalog has evergreen
content that's getting views 24 7 365
for years hopefully but I think smart
content creators 100
jump on
information opinion news-like content
because of the rapid views that it can
bring
so I would encourage you absolutely
create that kind of content the downside
is when does it end
the content doesn't have a shelf life
so you just then you find yourself on a
Content creation treadmill
and that's what we want to free people
from
so I create trend-based news-based
content early in the year I talked about
five trends for YouTube I talked about
the recession that appeared didn't seem
to happen but there was a Business
Insider I do a lot of uh reaction to
Business Insider articles and things
like that well that's
Trend that's news jacking Trend surfing
new surfing influence surfing if you
react to different stories
but what do I also have
thousands of ranked videos connected to
passive income streams that build us a
financial
Foundation of passive income that allows
us to truly build what we build at think
media
in summary it's not either or
it's both and
architectural sheet metal or metal how
do we squash limiting beliefs around the
direction we're headed I don't want to
limit my Reach for the Stars
it's a great question you know I think
rapid fire list is
get some good friends in your life
it left to your own thoughts
if you don't have good friends that you
could process this stuff with
uh you know we do have like pra welcome
parties we do have different meetups
that have happened inside of video
record Academy
um go to events you know my limiting
beliefs Kyle and I went to Miami last
week and uh that squashed my limiting
beliefs I mean that just sometimes it
takes a while you got to get in it's
worth buying take come to grow a video
live next year
um and be careful what you listen to
what you read
um
if possible create your own Mastermind
group like a pure LED Mastermind group
create a group of people that you can
get on and just process things with
listen all of us left to our own
thoughts in isolation we weren't meant
to be alone and that's not just like a
relationship or like romantic
relationship thing
I know for me man like leave me home
over the weekend just thinking
and I will catastrophize and build out
some situations that'll lead me to a
place
then I'll jump on with Melissa and Kyle
and like you know share where how dark
my world view has become
they'll be like
bro relax I mean I remember I was
processing something where I was like I
think our company is shrinking well I
think we're like about to go out of
business this is kind of where I was
emotionally I was like I don't know I
feel like we're stuck we're like we're
not growing we're not
and here's the principle do the math
and I was talking to somebody and they
helped me do the math and they're like
your Revenue company wide is up 15 I was
like
now good or bad like that's actually not
amazing depending on like when you're
running margins in a business
but it's not down that's like I wasn't
even I literally I felt like
we were in uh the red
the truth was we were in the black and
so
attained distance before deciding the
book decisive says sometimes you gotta
back up and sometimes it's hard to come
to positive conclusions now you also
might be like Sean but I'm in the
freaking red dog like my numbers are
down my Channel's shrinking my dog died
my wife left me someone just shot off my
right kneecap it's very painful
um I'm in the hospital okay that's a
bleak situation that's incredibly bleak
the human brain is still powerful though
like What scenario like did I just break
down that's pretty you're like you know
what there's no hope uh no there is
there's still like no matter how there's
always hope but I think you know hope is
oxygen to the human soul so I think it's
kind of getting back to a place of of
counting your blessings looking at the
bright side preparing uh charting a path
forward no matter how dark it is
if you're negative in your business if
your Channel's shrinking you could
complain worry
um you know
worries like a rocking chair just sit
there processing it this just sucks so
bad but that's not helpful so charting a
path is like okay
I'm Gonna Keep learning
how could I reinvent myself and to find
a new approach I'm going to find a new
strategy not gonna quit how do you get
into that state
by subscribing to the think media
podcast but I mean for real like by by
getting around information
people maybe maybe you're tired maybe
you need a nap tired eyes rarely see a
bright future
my mindset when I'm fatigued
is negative and then I take a nap and
I'm like oh okay it wasn't as bad as I
thought it was
um so I hope some of those things are
helpful and uh man the guy
the guy who got his right kneecap shot
off I mean that was that's a bad day I
haven't heard that one JP but that was
that was a whole nother hey welcome to
VRA Elite Corky appreciate you super
grateful for you I can't wait to see
inside
um yeah plus God activate Faith hey good
point and I mean uh important for you to
bring that up that is one of my passions
obviously you know
I had a sequence of things we come back
from Miami which was sick investing in
ourselves and you know again by the way
if you're not on the waiting list grow
with video live.com so we're gonna have
an event next year the no Miss event as
content creators business owners using
content
but then I also came back and I went to
church on I don't miss church on Sunday
so that is a rep it's a I I don't I
learned from Atomic habits you don't
rise to the level of your goals you
follow the level of your systems
I have systems in my life to guard my
soul
I have systems in my life I put gas in
my car consistently I don't run it to
empty
so it's burnt out on the side of the
road broken down and I got a call Triple
A or my wife to come bring me a can of
gas sometimes we push ourselves too hard
and we end up sidelined and the putter
our cars Putters to a stop well I want
to make sure that I'm refilling my take
on a systematic basis that's why I've
got a gauge and those gauges are an
indicator check engine light is telling
me to check the engine oh shoot I need
to do the oil I've been it's 7 000 miles
and I needed to change the oil at 5 000
miles one of those habits and routines
for me is being connected to a local
church but was also kind of crazy was
here in Snohomish and the Pacific
Northwest Marysville our church up here
is called The Pursuit and they're having
a conference and dude Monday night was
insane like we just I I literally in my
life I've never been a part of something
like this like the craziest
like for my people of faith I mean the
presence of God you talk about an
atmosphere where you're like okay
God is here like like the you could feel
the presence of God the power of God
like The Reef like that
is something that we were meant the New
Testament would even teach like that's
not just something that happens one time
like we're to gather in environments
where our faith is built where we can
pray for one another where we are
refreshed and refilled so yeah you
activate that spiritual Dimension I'm
super glad you brought that one up
um in terms of of
there's for me with the amount of
emotional roller coaster I'm on as an
entrepreneur dude if I miss church like
one week
I like and you know you just go through
prayer worship all that kind of stuff
makes it reminds me of King David he's
like you know all my enemies want to
kill me my whole life is around me I
feel like I'm sinking
homie dealt with depression huge levels
of discouragement
huge emotional rollercoaster you could
read about it in the songs but then he
would found he but God is my refuge
uh you know I've got a a rock that is
higher than I I've got an unshakable
Foundation
um I've got a canopy of protection over
my life God is my strength he prepares
my hands for battle with my fingers for
war even this morning at 8 30 a.m before
our 9 A.M meeting I was like I was in my
God's promises for your every need this
book is fire it's just scriptures that
are categorized in different promises
and uh I was like you know what I should
do
or am I looking
I should pray it's kind of funny like
it's it is kind of a habit but every
once in a while you know it's been a
while like when was the last time I even
like legitimately prayed and like when
was the last time I actually read the
Bible and didn't just listen to some
kind of you know and and it shifted my
whole outlook and shifted my spirit and
shifted my limiting beliefs remembering
that with man this is impossible but
With God all things are possible so if
you want to be in that all things are
possible you know type of mindset I
definitely encourage I know we have
people of different beliefs and
backgrounds but like I definitely
encourage you to uh
starve your fears and feed your faith
get connected to a really good local
church
and install some of those habits and
practices and systems in your life
to create Unstoppable momentum all right
we gotta land the plane but I got a
couple questions here vid IQ
but vid IQ suggests matching title and
thumbnail
they do
um
I'm not sure really what you're
referencing I do know that vid IQ
uh
has their AI tool that does like Auto
thumbnails
but vid IQ is
uh is a tool to assist
an intelligent strategist this is why
this is why like in my opinion it's not
like about like should I get vid IQ or
join your program VRA both
because it's like learning how to think
media podcast it's learning how to think
um and
even if but by the way that's true for
AI and AI is incredibly powerful we were
just talking about this Kyle and I were
hanging out talking about uh
uh
AI using AI it was a big conversation at
this conference we're at
and we use AI to come up with we use
chat CPT to come up with titles
a lot now but here's what was
interesting
there has never been one instance
that I have ever used chat gbt
a chat gbt title on a YouTube video
here's what I mean
I'll use chat GPT or vid iq's AI coach
to brainstorm and get some ideas for 10
titles recently I did three different
prompts in chat GPT came up with 30
titles
but I have never
used one of those titles as the final
YouTube title it has always been
adjusted modified tweaked based on
my marketing experience my psychology
experience studying copywriting studying
YouTube videos synthesizing it being a
human and not a robot and then and then
processing it from there which is a
summary of I think the power of AI in
general the power of AI
is it's helping me go faster it's
helping me I got writer's block it
breaks the the you know waterfall starts
to flood is I'm like okay cool now I got
some ideas okay cool let me go this
angle this angle okay I got all these
ideas okay and then I'll write out three
or four or five titles based on those
and I'm like I like that one
so it's powered up by process it's sped
up my process but it hasn't replaced it
so similarly
mid-journey or anything else like just
because it's like you enter something in
there you don't necessarily just roll
with what it gives you you need to have
those nuances that uh really only that
human perspective can help you with and
so duct tape unicycle AI isn't there to
work for you it's there to give you a
good Baseline and jump start your
creativity
I'm known to be long-winded and you that
is the exact sentence of what I was
trying to say thank you
all right one or two more here we got
house flipping people
uh may I know
what the rule of third in a thumbnail I
want to apply it up my channel Okay so
so let's talk about the rule of three in
thumbnails
it's not the rule of thirds
in thumbnails although that could be a
plaque applicable as well
okay so the rule of thirds
is a I think an important concept for
photography and it could influence your
thumbnail design
so the rule of thirds is you could see
where this person is framed that is the
rule of thirds so it kind of is it's uh
nice on the human eye this is a great
shot of what a cute dog and you can see
he's kind of uh there's there's two
pieces to where he he's framed over here
on the left oriented side of the screen
but also the upper left frame as well is
where his head is if that makes sense
somebody's probably better same idea
here so you see like the eye line is up
there and he's over on like the left
side of the screen that'd be kind of
like rule of thirds now the rule of
three in thumbnails was actually
inspired
from a study done of Netflix thumbnails
which if you want to talk about
world-class thumbnails you could learn
from Netflix and Hulu would be a good
thing to study
and what that taught was that
the best performing and best practices
of creating a thumbnail to get someone
to click on a piece of media
was that there was only Up Maximum three
objects or three things happening in the
thumbnail
now you got to know the rules so you can
break them so you may not always do that
but let me let me speak to how we apply
that on think media so Nolan
here what's the three things that are
that we see Nolan's face is one the
phone is two and the content on the
phone is three
um let's look at another obvious three
we have Sean here on the right
you've got the person you've got a play
button and you've got the text
now we also might apply that to we say
three or less words arguably no words
portable zoom two words and the the
lens
here's uh Ruslan Studio the subscribers
the person and then the don't use
editing software there's three things
there
so we try to limit it to Prime day tips
text the boxes to Sean three
now it's just a rule to know because
what we're after is Clarity simplicity
there's other contexts where you've got
to know the rules to break them I don't
think it works in every situation
today's video Sean the money the YouTube
but you also got day 30 in the arrow
that's basically three things but
yesterday's video
you really have just the one camera but
the the strategy was these are all look
how many cool things this one camera has
so if this is the best camera under
fifteen hundred dollars which by the way
if you're looking for a new camera head
over to the think media channel and
check out uh Omar's review of the a6700
it's it's fire and uh just dropped from
Sony
but
the simple it's still a simple thumbnail
but flip screen viewfinder smart cold
shoe sharp 4K no overheating sensor
stabilization and awareness of the
desires people want like on Sony they
want no overheating and that's been a
problem now you also got
excuse me cbe1 just the camera yes
almost holding it but he's it's kind of
like two things or you have the
background the camera being held by
hands and then the 90-day review text
um and then clearly here I think
aesthetically this is still simple
technically there is three microphones
because you have the receiver and the
two microphones
the word game changer and the red
background so there's four there but
like that's why it's like okay
rule of three but oh my gosh if I break
it
my channel will get shut down I'll get a
copyright strike if I highlight the
rules well too many people are doing
like the rule that's 26 like they got a
hundred words all these things they got
their logo for most of us it's just Sim
make it simpler cleaner zoom in a little
bit but that's the rule of three so the
like the the rule of three is is try to
have as as few things happening in the
thumbnail as possible but it's okay to
break the rule again 10 10 smart grown
update updates
here four are shown hopefully there's
diversity of the four things because
there's a microphone a battery pack
another microphone and a light also dark
background
dark battery dark microphone so blue
circle creates contrast so that you can
actually see those items pop out of the
background otherwise they would
disappear so just also trying to make
even your color contrast something that
you could do Nolan's laptop Nolan being
surprised and then paper flying around
more than one you know one piece of
paper obviously but but simple still
because you see all the different things
that are happening there really good
question the rule of three is powerful
great thumbs very clear some niches very
slightly I agree I totally agree and I
think
I think that success leaves Clues you
should search your Niche and search your
topic to see what the top ranked videos
are and some niches get away with a
lower quality standard of thumbnails
just meaning
some of the ranked trellis videos we saw
earlier were very not like impressive
thumbnails but they had a million views
because if it also can just be clear and
simple and speak to the audience
um for what they want
what do you do if you have a show with
three hosts and they are in the
thumbnail hmm
JP you have just asked
the ultimate question I think that Frodo
literally sawed off sought out Gandalf
to try to answer this question and it
stumped Gandalf he didn't know the
answer
I'm thankful that I do
um
what you do JP is number one
if you had a guest and they were a
celebrity guest
sometimes I recommend
just put the celebrity guest in the
thumbnail so the question is can you put
just one person in the thumbnail
there's the bigger question let's let's
take a step back
take all personalities and all egos out
of it so let's just assume that your
three hosts don't have such big egos
that they would be hurt if they weren't
in the thumbnail like why don't you show
me in the thumbnail it's not fair you
think you're better than me why are you
the real question should be what is
going to be most effective in any
organization oh you get more stage time
than me why do you get my time like work
at a church oh yeah I'm being overlooked
relax what is best for the organization
that might be true
but the question is like what's this
going to make it perform best
so the for like if you have two hosts
but one is like the main one
and no one's insecure then
you may just put the one host in the
thumbnail you don't have to force The
Two Hosts in the thumbnail or the three
hosts
um two I think that also
so here's what we ask on think media
podcast
back in the day we used to I used to
have a co-host
but what we would realize was like
I was still obviously the main
trainer person host so we had an option
me solo me and the co-host me and the
guest
only
and then the question is which is most
effective so like we have Alex tremozzi
on the podcast Alex Ramos is the only
person in the thumbnail
now you might ask well what would be
most valuable though is the fact that I
want to see Sean with Alex okay great
well that's a theory then let's try that
out because I see Alex everywhere and he
could just be by himself but I want to
see him with Sean because seanan's going
to ask a particular type of questions
okay cool
um
you know three uh
Colin samir's a good example they they
are Two Hosts and a lot of times they
have both faces not three
but when they have their guests it's
usually just the guest okay so just
different things you could potentially
think through
so I think you can experiment and then I
think different I mean all in podcast
this is just like quality Rises to the
top no matter how many cups of coffee
you pour
stuff like
by all arguments
these they should not win an award for
thumbnail design
but look at the views and I think
there's also because of who they are
you've got four Legends in investing
uh talking about stuff you know and so
uh people are here for a lot of other
reasons they're here for the
practicality of it so that's where some
of the stuff I gave you JP is also
if you haven't like built and sold a
tech company
for a hundred million dollars if you
have it you know it's kind of true like
if Elon Musk started a YouTube channel
his thumbnails probably wouldn't matter
so that's the mistake some people
project is they're like oh on the all-in
podcast their thumbnails aren't that
good yeah well what company did you
build how many Venture startups have you
done in Silicon Valley and are you worth
a billion dollars because if you aren't
then maybe people aren't like listening
to you yet they're not paying attention
to you as much so you maybe need to
learn good marketing tactics and think
about some different things because
you're building from scratch and this
person over here that's not doing best
practices has a lot of a celebrity
Authority and that's where they're
coming from
said with love
so then I think that
that's what I would consider is some of
those things and and do you need to
force all three guests in it and does
that end up becoming the brand success
leaves Clues you could study other
channels
um there's a lot of different ways you
could slice it up
um if you are The Three Amigos and the
three superheroes then I think it's does
anybody have any recommendations
um
here two of the hosts are celebrities
but the third host drives a conversation
it's the expert No guest
does anybody have any recommendations of
people pulling off really good
thumbnails with three people in it
what's that one big one
milk boys or whatever
what's their podcast
again I think that you've got full send
podcasts right
[Music]
um okay so but notice right okay so this
is a good example of three
they're getting away with three but it's
usually so they got it looks like they
maybe swap out the hosts I think forgive
me for not knowing these guys the guy on
the right here
looks like he's pretty consistently on
the right
but look at the guy on the left is
different oh no it's the same guy
but I know that I'm pretty sure there's
like four hosts or something here but
then and then I got Nate Diaz right so
you're gonna put that person in the
middle
um and so you also could get away with
just Hulk Hogan in this case and then
potentially
so yeah I mean you know switch it up do
whatever you want and and and try
different deals but I think that that
um
that example
yeah pbd podcast is interesting they
also though I feel like that's also like
a brand trust one like they all they'll
call it home team right they do home
team that's a clean way of doing four
and it says home team but no like also I
would say this
that title sucks
and I love pbd to death like home team
pbd podcast episode 301 like what are we
talking about now you know what I've
learned from them though is they
actually will go back and re-label some
of their podcasts and like backfill the
actual topics
um apparently not very often but uh
sometimes I've seen them do this like
yeah maybe here like DeSantis set to
announce on Twitter with Elon Musk
um and
sometimes but what's the point a you
actually listen to this because it's
part of your routine
it's current news it's currently
politics from their standpoint and
they've built Trust
B they cut the heck out of Clips like
they there's Clips man
55 uploads a month on this channel
so it's really smart because you have
the base episode but then you got value
attainment has got
another 89 uploads
okay and then if they're still doing
valuetainment short clips
let's see what sounds are Freedom yes
okay let's see valuetainment short clips
so 55 plus 89 plus 36
okay so 140 uploads just from those
three channels
and that's that's the uploads
you've got Clips I I bet that counts
shorts
what's the point
thinking about
your thumbnail and your three guests and
your three personalities are it's just
one entry point into your world so if if
you're building up trust with that brand
then keep having excellent content like
the pbd podcast and people a couple
hundred thousand viewers are watching
home team
pbd podcast episode 301 I don't even
know what I'm clicking on that for
but if it's part of my routine to always
listen to that podcast on my commute as
part of my daily content they're my guys
for news then that's they're just like
all in podcasts they built the trust and
maybe you love the home team more than
you even love a guest
um but as far as converting and meeting
people you've never met before
chances are they're not going to watch a
two-hour episode they have no idea who
pbd is or any of that stuff they're
gonna watch because he brings the
celebrity guest on oh my gosh who's this
guy who had Cuomo on and they're gonna
watch that
or even more they're going to watch a
viral clip covering a Hot Topic and then
be like oh and I love how this guy
processes issues and I love how you know
he communicates things
let me actually check out the full
episode and then maybe somebody falls in
love with the full episode
um okay so I appreciate you JB uh thank
you and for the question
and
the cool content uh conversation here at
the end uh can't get up you know trying
to get to as many questions as possible
but thank you for all the questions
today thank you for the guest today if
you haven't subscribed and turn on
notifications that's a must do why
because the coffee with Channel show is
happening pretty much every other week
now plus we've got your weekly podcast
and we got Clips on the channel and we
are actually continuing to have your
feedback in fact in fact I'm curious do
you watch every episode of the think
media podcast do you watch the clips
have you been liking the clips did you
even notice we're doing clips
are you mad about the clips
anything that you think we could do here
to improve on this channel I'm all ears
and we of course can watch the replay of
this chat as we land the plane today but
we are working on leveling up and
improving all of our content for you and
I want to send you love and respect and
gratitude today the coffee with candle
show is uh
is listen every episode Robert my fave
thank you so much appreciate you and uh
super grateful
uh we are we're working on improving get
one percent better with all the stuff
that we do
and so smash like subscribe if you're
not subscribed and I can't wait to see
you in a future episode of the coffee
with candle show my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel and we will
talk soon peace